welcome back so in this series we have kind of
broken up the gigantic field of reinforcement
learning into a number of subfields
so model based reinforcement learning
model free reinforcement learning on policy off
policy gradient based gradient free and today
we're going to be specifically talking about
model-based reinforcement learning this is uh
has a really rich history in optimization theory
dynamic programming nonlinear dynamics a lot of
this came about from richard bellman's bellman
optimality condition and dynamic programming
so bellman made a huge huge impact to the field
coming up with these kind of optimality problems
showing when you can solve subproblems
and still get a globally optimal solution
and those are still being used today in these
policy iteration and value iteration algorithms
and in optimal nonlinear control using
the hamilton jacobi bellman equation
so specifically today we're going to zoom in on
this block here and so we'll be talking about how
do you kind of iteratively optimize a policy
or a value function by solving sub-problems
with dynamic programming and so this is in
the context of a markov decision process we
assume that the environment that our agent is
interacting with is a markov decision process
so some probabilistic state transition
process okay and i'm going to jump in
to give you the details of dynamic programming
and policy iteration and value iteration i first
want to just recap the really really basic stuff
for reinforcement learning in case you're just
tuning in uh so our agent is interacting with an
environment it senses its state through a series
of measurements s at time one time two time three
this is an iterative measurement process we're
assuming a discrete system like playing a game
of chess where it's turn based and at each time
i get to decide on an action to take a to try to
hopefully maximize my future reward for this game
and we are trying to design an optimal policy pie
again that gives us the maximum future
rewards we have this value function v
that um given our policy pi it tells us how
advantageous is it what is the the expected
future rewards of being in this state now and
enacting this policy pie and it's a probabilistic
uh process so we're taking the expected value
of our future rewards given some policy pie
and i don't know the best policy or the true value
function for that best policy out of the gate
that's what i'm trying to learn i'm trying to
learn the optimal policy and ideally also an
optimal value function for what is the best state
to be in what we do assume that we know at the the
outset at least for this model based reinforcement
learning for kind of the simplistic version
is we assume that we have a model for how
the environment works how the system works
so we assume that the environment evolves
according to a markov decision process so that
would be this probability here so the probability
that the state of my system at the next time step
will be s prime is some some probability based on
or conditioned on my state currently being s and
my current action being a so given a current state
s and a current action a there is some probability
that my system will transition to a new state s
prime and that's encapsulated in this probability
model p this is called a markov decision process
and it generalizes a normal markov process
to have this action or control input a we
also assume that we have some model of what
the reward structure looks like so what is the
probability of a reward given some current state s
sorry given given a current state s and a
current action a and assuming that i move to
a future state s prime in the next state what is
my expected reward uh given all of that happening
so given kind of this information what is
my expected reward uh at the next time step
and again this is kind of an assumption that
you know the rules of the game you're playing
so if i'm playing chess for example you know the
reward only comes at the very end of the game
but i know what the rules to win are i know how
to checkmate someone or how to not checkmate
someone you have to know that going in to play
and so um this would basically say i know what
my reward is given a current you know like given
a future state and so this is the information
we have at the outset and we're trying to learn
an optimal policy and an optimal value function
uh that kind of allow you to best play
that game to maximize your future rewards
good and i'm going to walk through some properties
of the value function that allow you to solve this
problem this seems like a big brute force problem
let me let me take one step before i go into the
value function in the game of chess for example
there are so many possible boards configurations
the state s there are so many possible states
that your chessboard can be in something like you
know 10 to the 80. in fact fun fact the number
of possible boards of chess that you can have
is an unknown number we know that it's very large
you know 10 to the 80 or something on the order
but we don't know exactly what that number is and
i think that's kind of a fun fun fact that we know
it's huge but we can't actually perfectly quantify
what that number is uh it has someone famous name
but but that's neither here nor there
and so we can't actually compute this optimal
value function at all of those 10 to the 80
board conditions so um to solve for the
optimal policy and to get this optimal
value function would be a combinatorial like
brute force search over all possible states
and it just isn't even remotely feasible
okay so we need some alternative
and that's what the dynamic programming is going
to allow us to do is to break this up into smaller
sub-problems so that i can think of like what's
the optimal thing to do for three steps ahead
or for four steps ahead or for five steps ahead
that's actually how you know you learn to play
when you're a kid is you think a couple moves
ahead and you optimize for that that's what
dynamic programming allow us to do break this up
into smaller sub problems okay and so again the
goal is always to optimize the policy to maximize
future rewards that's all i can do as an agent
so we start with this value function given
some policy pi the value function at a given
state s is my expected future reward discounted
potentially by some gamma factor so this gamma
is a number between zero and one that discounts
future rewards over current rewards and that's
kind of an economic principle there's results that
show certain optimality and convergence criteria
for this kind of exponential decaying reward
function but that's what the value function does
is it basically adds up your expected future
reward be given that you're in a state s now
and you know your first state is s
and you enact an optimal policy pi
so it's kind of an implicit function of pi and
if i drop the subscript pi if i just talk about
the value function capital v then this capital v
value function is the value of being in a state
s assuming that i am working on the absolute
best possible policy again for any game that
you can name like chess or go like most games
you have no idea what this best policy is but
there is some hypothetical best policy pie and
if you always played that best possible policy pi
this v would be the value of being in a particular
state assuming you do the best thing possible
good uh and one of the really really cool
things so this is what bellman figured out
uh richard bellman kind of the rest was history
he figured this property out that allowed him
to invent dynamic programming uh and a large
part of the field of reinforcement learning
so this value function here this exact expression
you can take this sum of future rewards and break
it up into the current reward at time step now
zero means you know now plus all of the future
rewards starting at time step one to infinity that
you know so i take my my sum of all of my rewards
at time now to infinity and i break that up into
my reward now plus the sum of all of the rewards
at the next state to infinity so now this is uh
this is the reward given that my current state at
time now is s this is my reward given that my next
state s1 at the next time step is s prime and so
what this allows you to do is essentially rewrite
your value function your value function given
the best policy possible is whatever your current
reward is plus a discounted value function at this
next state s and so you can recursively define
your value function like this my value function
at my current state is a function is a function
of the value function at my next state s prime
and that's really really powerful so this means
that if i do the absolute if i know what this
value function is and i know what the best next
state is all i have to do is take an action now
to get me to that next best state in the future
and so this is a recursive expression that allows
you to break it up into sub problems this is
called bellman's equation or bellman's optimality
condition and if this is satisfied for a problem
if the the value function the thing you're trying
to optimize is a recursive function of itself at
the next time step you can break this problem
up into sub problems you can optimize locally
and if you optimize locally enough and all of
these different states and you put them together
you still have an optimal solution so basically
i can optimize this sub problem and then plug it
into this problem and it's still optimal
that's really simple but very powerful
and once i have my optimal value function so
assuming that i just you know i i did this and
i had this optimal value function and i maybe
someone handed me an optimal value function
then i can always extract from this this
expression here this optimal value function
I can always extract the policy
*pi* as the *pi* that maximizes this expectedreward.
It's a little circular... here we're
maximizing over the policy *pi* (this expression)
"argmax" means the *pi* that maximizes this expression.
So you can always extract a policy from a value function
and given a policy you can createa value function.
So this is Bellman's equation, and this is the basis of dynamic programming.
Dynamic programming is how we solve, how we build up this value function. Again, we assumewe know the rules of the game
but we don't know the value function or the optimal policy *pi*, and sowe can build this up even for complex games
using dynamic programming, as long as this equation istrue, and it's true for Markov decision processes.
So what Richard Bellman said, is essentially givensystems that are recursive sub-problems like this
you can break them up -- this multi-step optimizationproblem -- like how do I make a sequence of chessmoves to win a game?
I can break that upinto a number of smaller sub-problems
where if I optimize over those sub problems and
then I put them all together, I still have an
optimal action or policy. And there are a lot of details of dynamic programming
kind of how you program this up in a computer howyou actually do this... maybe that'll be adetailed lecture for another day.
There are kind oftwo big approaches: there is the top-down approachand the bottom-up approach.
So in the top-downapproach you essentially list out all possible
sub-problems... you kind of list out all possible
little sub-problems and you try to solve all
of them and you basically just keep track every
time you need a sub-problem you see if it has been
solved: if so, you use it, if not, you solve it.
Andrecursively you end up filling out this table of
subproblems until eventually you've kind of brute
force solved the whole thing. I'll point out you
can't solve chess using dynamic programming it's
too big you have to use other approximate methods
things like deep learning and things
like that but it's it's a good cartoon
you can solve tic-tac-toe using dynamic
programming that's one of my homework exercises
so the top-down approach is basically to
create this table or memoization of all
sub-problems and solve them as needed until
they're all solved um the bottom-up approach
is basically to um always start with the smallest
sub-problems and work your way back aggregating
them into bigger problems so the way you would
think about that is you would start from every
winning configuration every configuration
where you definitely got a reward and won
and then you'd optimize one step back what was
the best move to get me in that position and
then you'd optimize two steps back what was the
best move given that i want to be here to get
me in that position and you'd kind of recursively
build up bigger and bigger optimization sequence
from from these winning configurations or from
locations where you know you're getting a reward
this is a massive simplification but that's
the basic idea of dynamic programming
and although it's still very expensive and kind
of a brute force approach it's still better than a
naive brute force approach um dynamic programming
is really closely related for those of you who are
computer science people it's closely related
to divide and conquer methods except that
divide and conquer methods like the quick sort
algorithm specifically rely on your problem being
non-overlapping and non-recursive whereas these
are this is a recursive optimization so this
is a bit more sophisticated okay that was a lot
so now let's talk about how we actually do this
uh for value iteration for example so two
of the the leading algorithms that rely on
dynamic programming for model-based reinforcement
learning are value iteration and policy iteration
and so value iteration is essentially going to
allow me to use bellman's optimality condition
to iteratively build a refined estimate of myvalue
function through trial and error not through trial
and error through optimizing a sequence of events
through a known model and there's ways of tweaking
this so that you can do it through trial and error
that's called approximate dynamic programming
and i'll talk about that later so the
idea is that the value function again
we're trying to maximize over the best all the
possible actions we're maximizing that action
to give this optimal future reward and so it's
my reward now plus a discounted value function
at the next step in my model given that action
a and i'm you know i have to sum up over these
probabilities because this is a markov decision
process so if this was a deterministic process you
wouldn't have this sum and this probability but
this is essentially necessary because this is a
probabilistic markov process but this is the
thing we're trying to maximize over is our future
total reward which is my reward now given
this action i'm about to take and my future
value function my the sum of all my future rewards
discounted by gamma that's just this is literally
just this here rewritten and so uh what we're
essentially going to do is kind of iteratively
start to update this v given this situation
so we're going to in every sub problem
assuming that i have this assumes two things it
assumes that i know the model of where i will be
given an action uh in my from my current state
and it assumes that i know v at my next state
so i basically create a big table of my value
function at all of the possible states and i might
initialize it at zero or random or whatever and
then what i do is i start at a state some initial
i randomly pick a state i i start there and i
start kind of playing the game i start running
through action sequences and updating my estimate
of the value function so let's see how this works
i'm in a state s now and what i'm going to do
i actually can evaluate this function for all
actions because i know the reward function i know
the model p and i at least have a table of what
i think the optimal value function is at all next
states now that might be a really crummy estimate
this is kind of a v hat this is an estimate of the
value function it might be a garbage estimate but
it's something that's the best i got and so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to maximize
over all actions i'm going to compute this
for all actions and pick the best action
that gives me the maximum possible value assuming
this bad estimate here and i'm going to update
the value function at this current state s that
i'm currently at i'm going to take my table
find my current state and i'm going to
update that value function with this maximum
expected future reward then i take the next step
and i do the whole process again now i'm in a new
state and i find the best action you know this
assumes that i have some estimate of what my
value function is at the next state and i do this
again and again and again and even if this value
function was initialized badly when i run through
this time and time and time again i'm going to
iterate through this that's why it's called policy
iteration i i i iterate through the game i play a
game of chess i play another game of chess and
another one and another one and another one
and each time i'm updating my value function
based on what i think is the best action this
is on policy if you like and so eventually that
value function starts to get better and better
and better and the better the value function gets
the better i'm able to update my value function
because you know this is a recursive formula it's
a it's a really simple idea because it's recursive
i can just initialize everything poorly and then
iteratively kind of refine that value function
as i play the game and play the game and play the
game and i'm kind of virtually playing the game
you know a simulated version because i know
the rules and i know the probability here
so this has to be you have to have a model
to do this value iteration you need to know p
and you need to know what is the expected
s prime the next state given that p
now in this case once i've done this so i iterate
over my policy i play a game and then i reiterate
i play another game and i play another game maybe
i start from different random board positions and
then i play and i play and i play and i iterate
until this converges to within some tolerance now
again you can't do this for exceedingly large
problems where the state space is you know
billion or trillion or 10 to the 80 like in chess
but for small problems like tic-tac-toe you can
actually code this up and try it yourself okay
so i highly encourage you to enumerate all of the
states of a tic-tac-toe board and just initialize
some crappy random initial value to every possible
state and then run through this value iteration
some big for loop until you refine that estimate
and once that's converged you can then extract
the optimal policy as the a that maximizes this
thing you've been working with this thing here
so that's value iteration and this relies on
bellman's optimality condition and it uses dynamic
programming it's a type of dynamic programming
so the kind of other leading approach that was
value iteration policy iteration is just a little
bit more complicated but also very similar and
it's a two-step iteration process so what we do
is the first thing is we lock in a policy pi
so it's whatever we think is the best policy pi
and we iteratively update our value function
locking in that policy pi so we do the exact
same thing as before but instead of doing the max
over all actions a we just enact our whatever we
think our best policy is and again we you know
kind of iteratively update what the value is
for every state by walking through different
states and seeing what happens essentially
and then we lock in that value function after
we've iterated on that we lock in the value
function and then we sweep through uh the actions
and we try to iteratively update the policy
so that given a state s we can take the best
actions a that maximize our future rewards now
again that assumes that i have a good working
model of my value function at this state and at
all future states at the next state s prime now
again this might be a like this might be a bad
approximation of the value function here but
it's usually good enough to improve my policy
then once i improve my policy i lock my
policy and i do another value iteration
step and that might be still a crappy
policy and a bad estimate of the value
but it's good enough to improve my value
function and now based on that better value
function i lock that in and i improve my policy
based on that policy i improve my value function
and this iterative procedure again you iterate
until some convergence criteria this is a lot like
the kind of alternating alternating directions
optimization that we see in machine learning
so policy iteration often converges in fewer
iterations than pure value iteration so this
is often kind of a preferred approach in in a
lot of cases and again i would like you to try
on the game of tic-tac-toe write a program to do
value iteration write another one to do policy
iteration and compare how fast they converge which
one converges in uh in less iterations which one's
faster you know on your cpu so the last thing i
want to point out is that the value function v
where expect essentially you know optimizing the
action to maximize this future expected reward
this expectation here my reward now plus my you
know discounted all some of my future rewards
and when i compute my policy function pi i'm also
i'm trying to maximize over actions i'm trying to
find the action that maximizes this expectation
so it seems like there's redundant information
the value function and the policy function both
are intimately depending on this expectation
of all future rewards here and so it turns out
you can introduce something called the quality
function this q function which is the quality of
being jointly in a state s and taking an action a
and literally this quality function is that
expectation from before so this expectation
that we're we're trying to to estimate with our
value function or exploit with our policy is the
quality function it is the expected future current
and future rewards given a state s and an action a
now the q function it seems like i've just renamed
something i've already worked with and i have
but this is super super important
because when i did policy iteration
and value iteration i needed to have a model of
what my future state s prime is so that i could uh
use this value at that next state in my
optimization and my recursive dynamic programming
optimization whereas in the quality function if
i start to learn a quality function q of s and a
all of this information is implicitly in this
function and so i can optimize directly and learn
and iterate this quality function and iteratively
improve it and i don't need a model for what my
next state is because it's already implicitly
defined in the quality function that's a subtle
point but this quality function just writing it
so it's implicitly a function of the future state
instead of an explicit function means that i can
do uh model-free reinforcement learning i can
optimize this quantity directly without knowing
what my future state is going to be i can do this
by trial and error and again from this quality
function once i learn a good quality function
i can extract my value function or my policy
pi from this q function so this has all the
information i need to get my value function or my
optimal policy and so uh it's evolving that lots
and lots of modern reinforcement learning
algorithms really do rely on this quality
function so you have these deep quality networks
that have been revolutionary in playing uh atari
games so deepmind's atari game is a deep quality
network um the early versions of uh like alphago
you know use use these quality functions so
really really powerful powerful stuff here
okay we've talked about this block here where if
we have a markov decision process we can do policy
iteration or value iteration leveraging dynamic
programming and bellman optimality and we've
also shown how this quality function queue kind of
incorporates all of this information but hopefully
in a way that we can use for model free control
so we'll talk about that later all right thank you